there's been a reaction already to the
situation in myanmar to the school
in myanmar this monday the white house
issuing a statement
that says the united states opposes any
attempt to alter the outcome of recent
elections or impede myanmar's democratic
transition
and will take action against those
responsible if these steps are not
reversed they say we are monitoring the
situation closely and stand with the
people of burma
who have already endured so much in
their quest for democracy
and peace peace rather let's bring in
kwa winner who's the executive director
of burma human rights network he's via
skype joining us
uh thank you very much as we continue to
of course follow
uh these events unfolding today in
myanmar and a coup now and for days
there had been speculation
speculation about the military and what
it was going to do
it seems that this has now happened this
school that many people had
uh thought would happen what is your
reaction first to the military statement
about
why they're doing this now
i mean um what we clearly see is
this is a sub attaching
and destroying the democratic process
which has been so far
a little progress we have made you know
so this is a very unfortunate uh
event uh the military general
which actually you know they they are
afraid of their diminishing power
in burma and the uh intolerance with the
you know uh with the civilian government
and the way
civilian government has been getting
their support and and
vote you know during the election so
they have
created that false accusation that
the fraud there's been fraud in election
actually it is not that the main reason
is you see the according to the military
rule the main
general ming online has to retire very
soon because he's now age
65 above now and he have to retire soon
so he if he retired without any power
and he
he need to protect himself because he
have committed the genocide
against india people right so he need to
protect so he need to hold the higher
position
in the government so he wants to become
a president of some higher position
and he's not getting from nld without
any such in the current situation
so what do you think the move they have
made yeah what do you think is going to
happen now to ansuchi of course she was
under house arrest for some 15 years
before
uh becoming leader of myanmar the de
facto leader of myanmar
what's the military likely to do with
her now
military seems to be very stubborn and
they are not abide by the law they don't
care about any system any promise you
know yesterday they say something and
tomorrow they do something else so
it is very unlikely to predict them
but one of the key important point here
i would like to raise is
is very important how what is
international community going to do now
because international community has been
playing very weak
uh diplomatic uh you know um
what they say uh they have been very
weak response against the military so
far
even they have committed genocide and
there isn't any any
reaction proper solid reaction from
international community
so this encouraged them you know to
undermine any international
law any any rules so so we are facing
today
today we have this situation unfortunate
situation
because they never face any consequence
because what they have done okay
so and and and we think that we we urge
international community
okay there must be immediate targeted
sanction on this general
and their businesses immediately of
course it'll be interesting to see what
the international community does there's
already been condemnation from the u.s
whether there'll be sanctions remains to
be seen thank you very much for speaking
to us
kwa wynn who's the executive director of
burma human rights
network